[Música]
muy buenas noches soy santiago lópez
gonzález bienvenidos a este especial de
france 24 con motivo del inicio de la
convención nacional republicana que
tiene lugar en la ciudad de charlotte en
el estado de carolina del norte una
convención que comenzó con actividades
desde muy temprano en la mañana del día
de hoy y ya está en este momento en
desarrollo las diferentes intervenciones
de las personas que han sido invitadas
como oradores para la primera noche de
el día de hoy a lo largo de poco más dos
horas y media vamos a estar con ustedes
en vivo y en directo conectándonos con
nuestras corresponsables en las ciudades
de nueva york y de washington y también
con invitados que hemos convocado para
hacer análisis de todo lo que se dice
importantes puntos en la política de
eeuu que tienen lugar en esta convención
en republicana que ya en las horas de la
mañana nomino al presidente de donald
trump y al vicepresidente mike pence
como la fórmula para volver a intentar
mantenerse allí en el poder en la casa
blanca en washington y no permitir una
alternancia de poder a los demócratas
allí en estado
más adelante estaremos conectándonos con
nuestros corresponsales para ver cómo
está el ambiente en estas ciudades ver
cómo se prepararon allí en washington y
en nueva york' y de cara a este evento
porque esto llega después de una semana
de ser celebrada precisamente la
convención o por parte de los demócratas
que fue totalmente virtual fueron
intervenciones pregrabadas que fueron
presentadas a lo largo de las jornadas
la de los republicanos que van a
comenzar el día de hoy o que comenzaron
el día de hoy tienen ambas cosas tienen
parte virtual debido a la pandemia del
jove 19 como medida de bioseguridad pero
también cuenta con muchísimos invitados
que van a estar participando allí en el
escenario en el spektrum center en la
ciudad de charlotte se estima que unas
50.000 personas van a pasar a lo largo
de esta semana para atender allí este
importante evento político voy a
mostrarles en la siguiente gráfica
quiénes son las personas más destacadas
que van a estar allí en este escenario y
hablando sobre la importancia de los
valores del partido republicano y
confirmando precisamente al presidente
de donald trump ya mike pence
como sus candidatos para las siguientes
elecciones que serán llevadas a cabo el
3 de noviembre ahí tenemos una imagen a
nicky reilly ella es embajadora de eeuu
ante la organización de naciones unidas
también estará allá en este escenario
thomas scott él es senador por el estado
de carolina del sur ven ustedes hay una
pareja ellos son marc y patrícia mccloud
si ellos son mccloskey ellos son de la
ciudad de san luis en el estado de
misurí ellos son conocidos en la unión
americana por haber apuntado y amenazado
con armas a manifestantes del movimiento
black life matters y ambos son acusados
de delitos graves con arma una
invitación a participar en esta
convención que ha llamado mucho la
atención en diferentes sectores de la
sociedad estadounidense un aspecto
importante que vamos a analizar a lo
largo de la noche con nuestros invitados
y también aparece en el último rincón de
esta imagen
donald trump juniors que es el hijo del
actual mandatario y es también llamado
por algunos sectores políticos como
hacer el sucesor de donald trump
en el año 2024 para continuar con esta
dinastía digámoslo así de ser elegido en
el 2024 de mandatarios de la familia
trump que sería entonces este de ser
votado con la mayoría en el mes de
noviembre un segundo periodo por otros
cuatro años que le permitirían a donald
trump seguir cuatro años más en la casa
blanca precisamente el presidente de
donald trump estuvo en los eventos de
esta mañana allí en la ciudad de
charlotte y se pronunció ante los
asistentes que estaban allí esto fue lo
que dijo adiós quiero agradecer a las
personas de carolina del norte porque
para ser honesto con ustedes me siento
en la obligación de estar aquí ustedes
tienen un gobernador que está en ánimo
de cierre total les garantizo que el 4
de noviembre todo se abrirá todo estará
bien como en otros estados el 4 de
noviembre y ustedes saben esos
gobernadores demócratas ellos aman el
cierre hasta después de que terminen las
elecciones porque quieren que nuestras
cifras económicas se vean lo peor
posible y no vamos hasta washington con
diana castañeda nuestra corresponsal
allí en la capital de eeuu diana
comienza
el termómetro a lo largo de la jornada
de hoy para los republicanos cómo se
preparó la capital estadounidense para
este evento qué es lo que se vive allí
en este momento dan los detalles
hola qué tal acidez se trata de una
convención un poco diferente a la
demócrata vimos que la demócrata fue
totalmente virtual y que digamos si yo
un poco la línea tradicional de la
política y de la nominación que se dan
estas convenciones ahora esta convención
republicana tiene la particularidad que
empezó su transmisión mucho más temprano
que va a ser mitad
online en línea pero también va a tener
algunas apariciones como vimos de la
aparición sorpresa de donald trump en un
recinto y obviamente pues también
tendrán discursos de personajes que
representan el partido republicano pero
también de muchos de los miembros de la
familia del presidente de donald trump y
también rompe con la tradición de llegar
a este conteo de los delegados y de
tener su apoyo en la mitad de la
convención y fueron los delegados
quienes ya dieron este reconocimiento
oficial de nominar al presidente de
donald trump y al vice
presidente pienso para la presidencia y
vicepresidencia en esta campaña por la
reelección en las elecciones de
noviembre 3
ahora también veremos hay algo en común
entre estas dos convenciones y es que el
presidente dará un discurso de
aceptación de la nominación y se espera
que lo haga desde aquí desde washington
desde la casa blanca también mañana la
primera dama dará un discurso lo hará
desde los jardines de la casa blanca y
tendrán temáticas por día hoy la
temática es una nación de oportunidades
y se espera que haya digamos que existan
tres temas centrales que se desarrollen
durante estas presentaciones de esta
noche el primero según los republicanos
del derecho que se debe defender en los
eeuu para que las personas puedan portar
armas que están marcados en la segunda
enmienda de la constitución otra de las
prioridades será la necesidad que tiene
el partido reforzar la idea de controlar
la inmigración
y llegar a través de la frontera con
méxico y también defender el ejercicio y
el derecho al trabajo que tienen los
departamentos de policía en toda la
nación que son aristas completamente
diferentes en la posición política más
conservadoras en comparación a la línea
que vimos con la convención demócrata la
semana pasada
y ahora pues una gran panorama que nos
ha dado allí en cuanto a la agenda que
está teniendo lugar en este primer día y
en el spektrum center en charlotte con
motivo de esta convención republicana
quiero ir ahora con mamen sala en la
ciudad de nueva york importante punto de
votación es también una ciudad que
congrega a muchísimos emigrantes es una
ciudad multiétnica y es un importante
punto de votación y decisivo también en
las jornadas y pues es importante
conocer qué es lo que está sucediendo
allí con los simpatizantes del partido
republicano precisamente para ver cómo
está el panorama si está mamen salam
amén buenas noches y cómo se ha vivido
esta jornada el inicio de la convención
republicana allí en la ciudad de nueva
york
bien muy buenas noches desde aquí desde
nueva york la verdad es que está siendo
una jornada rana histórica e inusual por
la situación pandémica en la que nos
encontramos sí que es cierto que ni la
semana pasada que era la convención
demócrata y eso que aquí nueva york es
un estado mayoritariamente demócrata
donde más del 80% de la población
vota al partido demócrata no hubo
grandes representaciones en la vía
pública como habíamos visto en
anteriores ocasiones en este caso esta
semana tampoco está ocurriendo con la
convención republicana se echan de menos
estas gorras de este merchandising o
esos carteles en la vía pública esta va
a ser desde luego una convención muy
diferente a la que vimos la semana
pasada y ya ha comenzado desde primera
hora de la mañana cuando hemos visto esa
nominación por el donald trámites que se
ha hecho pues bueno antes a una
audiencia no ha sido algo de manera
virtual como veíamos en el caso de los
demócratas hemos escuchado a donald tran
hemos escuchado abucheos de aplauso es
algo que no vimos en algunos bien el
discurso
del candidato demócrata hasta ahora hace
poquito más de media hora que ha
empezado esta convención y hemos
escuchado pues también ciudadanos como
por ejemplo una profesora de un colegio
público o la propietaria de una
cafetería en montana que ha conseguido
reflotar su negocio gracias a la ayuda
por parte del estado va a ser una
convención
diferente en todos los sentidos incluso
a los propios periodistas nos acosen nos
ha costado seguir la agenda de toda esta
semana porque ya no solamente porque se
ha estado cerrando este último momento
sino también porque el propio donald
trump que como saben es un tiburón
televisivo quiere mantener también
algunos elementos de sorpresa a lo largo
de esta convención y desde luego
sorpresas tenemos como esta pareja
santiago que apuntaba hace un momento de
san luís que apuntó con un arma a los
manifestantes durante las protestas van
a tener también su momento para hablar
en esta convención y otra cosa que
también me ha llamado la atención es que
de momento no hemos visto el poquito
tiempo que hemos visto al presidente
donald trump
con la mascarilla algo que sí que vimos
muy presente en la convención demócrata
veremos a ver cómo se desarrollan estas
cuatro jornadas de acuerdo a la agenda
que ha dado a conocer el partido
republicano el presidente trump
intervendrá en todas las convenciones a
lo largo de esta semana hasta el jueves
cuando este gran discurso que como diana
nos decía va a ser desde los jardines de
la casa blanca que también ha generado
muchísima controversia entre los
estadounidenses porque piensan que ven a
un candidato que está haciendo este
discurso de cierre desde una entidad
estatal desde la casa presidencial
precisamente que puede enviar un mensaje
equivocado a los votantes o puede
generar confusión según decían algunos
analistas y algunos periodistas allí en
eeuu tema que también vamos a hablar más
adelante con nuestros invitados
aquí en américa latina en donde no
existen este tipo de convenciones nos
resulta un poco extraño esta dinámica y
estas convenciones tienen lugar cada 4
años de cara a las elecciones
presidenciales es el momento en que los
dos partidos dominan oficialmente a los
candidatos que van a participar en esa
contienda del lector
y quiénes son los que van a llegar a esa
disputa por la casa blanca así que de
ahí viene la importancia este año como
ellos como nuestros corresponsables nos
decían la dinámica ha cambiado por las
medidas de bioseguridad pero la esencia
en sí de las de las convenciones son las
mismas allí los partidos aportan cuáles
van a ser las plataformas políticas que
van a tener también definen algunas de
las reglas que van a tener a lo largo de
campaña y dejan ver un poco cuáles van a
ser esos ejes centrales de ese gobierno
de cuatro años que van a tener en desde
la casa blanca también permite que
diferentes voces como decía mamen
profesores integrantes de la sociedad de
eeuu
funcionarios del gobierno gobernantes
estatales todo tipo de personas pasen
por este escenario para revalidar y para
fortalecer esos valores partidistas que
es lo que estamos viendo en este momento
si ustedes ven ahí en las en las
imágenes que están llegando en este
momento desde la ciudad de charlotte en
el estado de carolina del norte
y tipos también aprovechan para hacer un
poco de crítica al gobierno de turno
para criticar algunas políticas para
criticar a la oposición y es una
verdadera fiesta electoral para eeuu es
un momento muy importante y es
prácticamente el punto de partida de
inicio de las elecciones para este país
norteamericano tiene en la ciudad de
washington usted nos mencionaba una de
las particularidades que tiene esta
convención republicana y es que van a
participar a parte de estos integrantes
de la sociedad civil y funcionarios y
gobernantes estatales va a haber muchos
presentes allí es parte de la familia
trümper su esposa algunos de sus hijos
estarán allí en este escenario hablando
precisamente sobre los valores del
partido y sobre lo que ha sido la
gestión de donald trump porque tiene
esta particularidad es parte también de
esta campaña que está haciendo ya el
presidente trompa para ser reelegido
diana allí en la ciudad de washington
si hoy veremos por ejemplo al hijo mayor
del presidente dar un discurso veremos
mañana a su esposa a la primera dama
también su hija ivanka será la encargada
de presentarlo cuando ya dé el discurso
de nominación y aceptación oficial así
que lo que estamos viendo es como esto
pretende enviar un mensaje también de
unidad familiar uno de los valores que
representa el partido republicano es
precisamente esa familia tradicional y
veíamos también como al comienzo de esta
convención era el encargado de abrir la
transmisión oficial en horario prime un
cura un sacerdote y estos digamos son
los valores que quiere mostrar en esta
transmisión también que están reforzados
por los miembros de la familia del
presidente
donald trump pero también estarán
hablando
los familiares del mandatario sobre
cuáles eran las prioridades que tendrá
el presidente si llega a ser reelegido y
uno de los temas por supuesto de los que
estarán hablando será no solamente de la
creación de trabajos que ha prometido el
presidente donald trump sino también de
una recuperación rápida frente a esta
pandemia una de las promesas y que
digamos ha dado a conocer el partido
republicano de la plataforma que el
presidente quiere lanzar durante estos
cuatro días para el próximo año tiene
que ver con la pandemia asegurando que
tendrá lista la vacuna para final de año
y que todo volverá a la normalidad para
2021 estos dos objetivos hacen parte de
lo que el presidente anunciará en
materia de las promesas que tendrá que
realizar y llevar a cabo si llega a la
casa blanca de nuevo en el 2021 así que
digamos que cada uno de los aspectos que
hemos visto que hacen parte de esta
convención las historias de las personas
que van a reforzar esta narrativa
del partido mostrando cómo se han visto
beneficiados por las políticas del
presidente
donald trump al igual que la presencia
de su familia de líderes del partido
republicano de el líder republicano en
el senado entre otros pues hace parte
del mensaje que quiere enviar el
presidente para ser reelegido este año
ya nada menos que justamente el vice
presidente mike pence candidato ya como
lo dice ya esta convención de acuerdo a
los hechos ocurridos esta mañana dijo
que el punto clave de esta elección del
2020 era la economía que de hecho era la
carta para apostar por parte del
presidente como buena gestión de esos
cuatro años de gobierno que ya llevan la
casa blanca y que no era la democracia
como lo dijeron durante la convención de
los demócratas la semana pasada entonces
pues ahí se ve un poco el enfoque que va
a tener este gobierno de cuatro años de
ser reelegido el presidente trump en la
casa blanca tendría un fuerte enfoque
económico porque precisamente era su
carta
a presentar pero la pandemia de kobe 19
cambió muchísimo los planes en los
últimos meses y pues vino abajo toda esa
estructura que él había logrado
conseguir en estos meses de gobierno
vamos a ir entonces en vivo hasta la
ciudad de charlotte en el estado de
carolina del norte para conocer un poco
allí que lo que está sucediendo vamos a
conectarnos en vivo a ver qué están
transmitiendo en este momento y volvemos
con más análisis y más datos de
importancia aquí con nuestras
corresponsables
la investigación de moler y el sporting
falso pero a pesar de todas las
posiciones de los moriscos el presidente
ha hecho lo que iba a hacer ha reducido
los impuestos las regulaciones crece la
economía el desempleo y una nueva
embajada
y está construyendo un muro y
reconstruyendo la economía mientras
hablamos estábamos la intensidad del
presidente y su deseo por luchar por
nuestras familias pero también aprecio
algo que normalmente no ven los las
demás personas como cuida a las personas
hace dos años
nuestro sobrino murió en un accidente
era un atleta increíble en wisconsin era
un sábado después de tres días después
del accidente
llegué y me llamó el presidente hablamos
sobre algunos temas y luego me pregunto
cómo estaba mi familia le dije están
bien pero es difícil
el presidente dijo si perder a alguien
es muy difícil y es muy difícil cuando
es alguien tan joven así que elige
presidente estoy llegando a su casa en
este momento obviamente no saben que
estoy hablando con usted pero si usted
es saluda al papá de él hay va a ser
esto un poco menos bueno esta es una de
estas intervenciones que tienen lugar en
esta
nacional republicana como les decíamos
parte de ella va a ser virtual
pregrabada como este mensaje que están
viendo que estábamos viendo hace algunos
segundos que hace parte de esas
intervenciones de esos oradores
invitados que han sido convocados en
esta jornada de cuatro días para
reforzar los valores del partido y para
hablar de experiencias y para contarle
al resto de la nación
sus puntos a favor en cuanto a términos
políticos se refiere con el partido
demócrata que el partido republicano
como los ha favorecido las políticas y
esos momentos en los que la política del
gobierno los ha beneficiado en los
diferentes momentos difíciles en los que
pueden haber estado alguno de los
ciudadanos estadounidenses vamos a
presentarle a dos de nuestros invitados
está con nosotros entonces carlos arias
él es docente de la maestría en
comunicación política de la universidad
externado de colombia y también es
gerente de la firma estrategia y poder
se encuentra con nosotros desde la
ciudad de bogotá y también está con
nosotros julio healing él es politólogo
escritor y estratega republicano
director de patria de martí se conecta a
este análisis de france 24 desde la
ciudad de miami a los dos les agradezco
y les doy la bienvenida por estar con
nosotros aquí en france 24 gracias y
quiero comenzar con con julio schilling
como ya lo decíamos politólogo y
estratega estratega republicano una
noche muy importante para ustedes para
el inicio para empezar a lanzar entonces
las cartas sobre la mesa de cómo va a
ser esta contienda electoral
por supuesto ese se inicia una jornada
histórica e histórica no sólo por la
cuestión de la pandemia sino la segunda
vez que se va a repetir una victoria
presidencial una victoria electoral pese
a todas las encuestas que no dudaban y
en esta ocasión
ha de ser con mayor y con mayor ímpetu
por las razones claras de la enormes
diferencias que hay en ver los problemas
que está atravesando en la nación
estadounidense y el recetario que tiene
para resolverlo de manera de que esa
mayoría excelente que de nuevo en el 3
de noviembre no será tan excelente pues
está
precisamente en celebración
en estos días y no quiero decir bueno
que los números van a haber más más
vistas porque de nuevo eso no es lo
importante lo importante es lo que se va
a decidir el 3 de noviembre es la pauta
que da y afirmada y pues porque además
éste es el apenas el inicio de esta
campaña electoral y ya los antecedentes
en elecciones anteriores nos han
indicado que todo puede cambiar en
cuestión de semanas entonces este
solamente la línea el punto de partida y
todo puede cambiar
carlos áreas en la ciudad de bogotá
particularidades no encuentra me imagino
usted en esta convención en donde el
presidente trompo va a estar presente
todos los días dando un discurso
hablándole a los presentes allí en el
spektrum se enteren en charlotte ya lo
hizo por la mañana y también muchos
integrantes de su familia esto a nivel
estratégico a nivel político tiene
antecedentes ya en estas convenciones en
eeuu como se percibe eso
y mira que todo buenas noches santiago
buenas noches a todos los televidentes
de france 24 básicamente lo que está
haciendo tromba es un ejercicio de
permanencia y recordación durante toda
la convención por esa razón invitó a
toda su familia un hecho sin precedentes
a pesar de que en otras ocasiones tanto
el partido republicano como el partido
demócrata sean invitados familiares de
los candidatos en esta ocasión ver a
toda la prácticamente casi toda la
familia y muy bien repartidos cuando
digo repartidos es estratégicamente
ubicados en los diferentes días y en los
diferentes momentos de la convención y
también un ejercicio interesantísimo que
es fuera de lo que convencionalmente se
ha presentado y es que trump irrumpe en
la convención desde el primer día y no
solamente hasta el final acb hace
entrever que lo que está jugando trump
es lo que todos sabíamos que iba a jugar
y es el aprendiz ese es un nuevo reality
show y tampoco es gratuito que en este
momento parte del equipo de producción
de su programa de televisión el aprendiz
dentro de la convención y esté
desarrollando toda la estrategia
mediática y de manejo de emocionalidad
es a través de toda la visión
interesante punto de vista a carlos
arias desde la ciudad de bogotá
conectó también entonces con el señor
luis montes él es analista político
internacional es estratega demócrata y
socio fundador de pan-american
communication está en la ciudad de nueva
york y también se une a este debate para
llevarnos el otro punto de vista de este
debate en términos políticos en señor
montes gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en france24 y sus opiniones
perspectivas de este inicio de la
campaña de los republicanos después de
una semana intensa de el lado demócrata
en donde pues ya dejaron ver algunas de
las cartas que se van a jugar a lo largo
de esta carrera a la presidencia
bueno buenas noches interesante el
momento histórico que vive eeuu
obviamente en esta primera vez que se
dan ambas convenciones a nivel virtual
es interesante ver como por ejemplo la
la convención de demócrata la semana
pasada y fue hecha para este tipo de
formato en este sentido hemos vamos a
ver un cambio en la parte republicana
ellos
de hecho han concentrado la valla
las personas con hablar tanto en
washington como en carolina del norte
me parece que va a ser interesante ver y
esto es el la cúspide de la del ego
latría verdad por parte del presidente
trump donde por primera vez un candidato
presidencial
va a aparecer las cuatro noches de que
son estas convenciones tradicionalmente
el candidato aparece
vaya por brevemente durante esas noches
pero en esta ecuación trump se ha
reservado la hora a las 10 de la noche
hora del este de eeuu para poder hablar
una y otra vez esto obviamente no
sorprende porque es parte de lo que nos
tiene acostumbrado a él le encantan los
rallies a él le encanta
oírse hablar y en este sentido pues
vamos a ver qué verdad vamos a ver más
de lo mismo señor schilling usted está
en la ciudad de miami su opinión sobre
sobre este particular esta presencia del
presidente trump en todas las noches con
algún discurso y tener a su familia
participando también allí reforzando el
mensaje partidista y su mensaje de
campaña
cuando el otro señor no empezó a hablar
de lo vivo la tría y odio pero no
estamos hablando de la convención
republicano vamos a hablar del ex
presidente obama en la convención de
bóveda que está ahí para en efecto el
dorsal valle y lo único que hizo hablar
puede o sea y la esposa básicamente lo
mismo es una buena campaña para ella
misma entonces la gran molesta yo lo
entiendo que tienen el partido demócrata
es que este un presidente muy popular
con la sociedad estadounidense que la
cámara lo trata muy bien y pues eso es
un gran problema porque porque es
sincero es honesto parte de una élite
y supremacista la verdad que se cree
soberbia que se cree capaz de micro
manejar la vida de toda una sociedad
como ingenieros sociales y este
presidente es todo lo es lo contrario el
hecho de que precisamente abraza una
visión diferente a muchos dentro de su
propio partido sea un nacionalismo
económico o una visión de retar a
enemigos como china o comunista el
primer presidente en hacerlo en enfocar
en ayudar al obrero estadounidense pues
todos estos son puntos que naturalmente
ha dejado al partido demócrata perplejo
porque se consideraban dueños de este
tipo de terreno entonces el presidente
como lo critican tanto pues él sabe que
si él va en un lugar le van a dar la
publicidad y en el 2016 vimos que le
dieron una cantidad de publicidad
gratuita pensando que lo iban a hundir y
realmente fue todo lo contrario pues
está aprovechando eso y el hecho de
tener la familia bueno los clinton
tenían h
y si tenía los colores tenía su hermano
o sea eso es un lóbulo normal sí señor
si le entremos ya en material de los
temas que se van a se están tratando
esta noche allí en charlotte en carolina
del norte en la temática de la noche de
hoy es tierra de promesas y los temas a
analizar a profundizar allí es este
énfasis en la promoción del derecho al
porte de armas algo muy controvertido en
eeuu dado los antecedentes que han
tenido lugar en los últimos años la
defensa del trabajo de los cuerpos de
policía también en el ojo de la mira y
del análisis y los controles a los
migrantes su opinión todo está ligado a
un frente que estamos hablando de frenar
el avance del socialismo con esto
prácticamente el efecto sublevación
de organizaciones marxistas los eeuu
fundamental es defender la segunda
enmienda que es un derecho
constitucional pero mira tenemos el
ejemplo de méxico méxico tiene en su
constitución también el derecho de
portar armas sin embargo las leyes
complementarias han anulado esa
posibilidad eso es lo que quieren hacer
los demócratas entonces el hecho de que
hay más personas comprando armas que
nunca jamás te demuestre lo que lo están
comprando no solo son republicanos son
muchos demócratas que también se están
armando porque ven precisamente la
inercia del partido demócrata de poder
defender a sus ciudadanos entonces este
evento va precisamente a reforzar esa
posición que está en línea con la
excepcionalidad estadounidense señor
amante de su opinión sobre estos ejes de
temas de esta noche desde la perspectiva
demócrata
bueno nos parece que van a ser
obviamente un poco más de los mismos por
los últimos cuatro años el partido
republicano ha apostado a exacerbar
emociones de una pequeña minoría a un
38% de la del electorado
y esto es aún más de lo mismo en lugar
de estar hablando de unión del país en
lugar de estar hablando de algo vaya
verdaderamente de futuro lo cierto es
que trump quiere correr del récord que
tiene en el 2016 cuando ocurrió contra
una figura bastante polarizante como fue
hillary clinton es fue fácil para él
hacer el caso porque obviamente es decir
quintana bien es una pugna hay que
reconocerlo es una web es una figura
bastante polarizante o se ama o se odia
lastimosamente ahora con jan en su
reelección esto es un referendo sobre su
administración el muchas las promesas
que ha hecho hemos visto como una y otra
vez por ejemplo han habido muchos de sus
asociados que han sido verdad que están
vaya enfrentando la justicia en eeuu más
recientemente esteban quien con esta
promesa de construir el muro que nunca
se va a construir y que recordamos el
2016 iba a ser pagado por méxico
obviamente esto no se da igual
ahora en la noche con estas cuestiones
de las armas creo que todos en eeuu
están de acuerdo al art
digamos a unas aún a una medida sensata
en base al al chequeo la mayoría de los
del de los votantes es sobre la compra
de armas con uso con él con él
vaya con él va con de vido
de verdad con el chequeo desde el pasado
debido y creo que esos son asuntos que
el que trump trata de exacerbar a través
de estos discursos y lo mismo está con
la cuestión de la policía nadie hay que
verlo nicky mismo en eeuu las
comunidades minoritarias tanto
afroamericana como hispana como
asiáticos están en contra de la policía
al contrario esas son estas son las
comunidades que más se benefician de la
cuestión pública y del cuido policial
entonces pero es de una manera bastante
vaya mal intencionada el trump busca
exacerbar esos cisma carlos usted que es
estratega político y de comunicación no
es muy riesgoso comenzar una campaña
presidencial con temas tan
controvertidos bueno ya sabemos que el
presidente trump resulta siempre
bastante controvertido en sus decisiones
y como lo menciona nuestros invitados es
una figura que polariza y genera odios o
pasiones pero comenzar con estos temas
que para la sociedad de eeuu resultan
tan complejos es un buen punto
partida o es necesario de frente
arrancar con las problemáticas que tiene
el país bien antes de responderle un
elemento adicional bien importante y es
que quieren lo que está en juego es
exacerbar las emociones este no es un
juego de razones ni es un juego en donde
la mesura y la construcción conceptual
de qué propuesta es más apropiada en
términos de cómo se va a desarrollar al
final lo que está en juego es cómo
exacerbó yo las emociones alrededor de
mi discurso como logro yo ponderar este
ejercicio de reflexión que los críticos
y que los medios convencionales han
hecho de trump y lo llevó al límite de
la emoción para poder exacerbar a esa
emoción y jalar al electorado entonces
en esa medida y aparentaba responder lo
que usted acababa de preguntar santiago
y la estrategia de trump es muy buena
puede que nos guste o no pero es muy
buena y ahí es cuando empecé a
responderle
desde un ejercicio mucho más ponderado
mucho más llamado a la construcción de
una democracia en donde la inclusión en
donde los valores sociales y
democráticos en donde todos cabemos pues
no llamaría a este tipo de temas
inicialmente sino que entraríamos a
resolver digamos que los temas mucho más
de fondo y no los estos temas de
coyuntura que llaman a los medios de
comunicación pero es que es en el trompo
trump es esa persona que busca exacerbar
las emociones y que por eso pone toda la
carne en el asador pone toda la leña al
fuego al inicio porque sabe que desde
allí puede brotar todo ese ejercicio de
polarización que él necesita para
empezar a raspar le y a rasgarle esos
puntos de ventaja que tiene hoy y yo
bailo y una última al final si ustedes
miran detenidamente en los números uno
pensaría que después de la convención
demócrata
bardem si va a disparar y nos estamos
dando cuenta que no despega lo que entre
comillas deberían despegado ahora bien
también en un escenario muy singular
tenemos a un presidente que al intentar
reelegirse está perdiendo y eso no
ocurría hace mucho tiempo en la historia
de los eeuu comúnmente el presidente
cuando buscaba su reelección estaba
llevando siempre por la delantera al que
iba detrás claro el presidente llega a
este escenario con de acuerdo a las
últimas encuestas con ocho puntos por
debajo de joe biden y si resulta curioso
que joe biden no no se disparó no tuvo
un incremento en esas en esas
preferencias de voto después de la
convención demócrata señor schilling
como ven ustedes estas encuestas que les
dan precisamente estos ocho puntos por
debajo de bailén tienen ustedes el
antecedente de la elección pasada del
2016 que era un escenario similar
comenzaba en las convenciones
trump estaba de segundo y bueno llegó a
la presidencia
santiago a mí me sorprende que las
personas se sorprendan
el partido demócrata y el candidato by
mi pueblo no han tenido un despegue
primero y esto lo digo con seriedad y
mayor respeto ustedes también de modo
privado se pueden hacer ese examen
bardem tiene razones por la cual no ha
hecho una entrevista a un periodista
serio y no me refiero un periodista ni
de derecha ni ni que se pudiera pensar
fuera republicano ni siquiera
periodistas demócrata porque hay una
cierta incoherencia mental que realmente
cualquier persona lo puede poner sobre
el tapete yo creo que eso es una
realidad
baires no excita a nadie para nada
cuando hablo de apelar a la emoción que
se mencionó
qué política anunciaron los demócratas
en la semana pasada excepto el odio a
trump de nuevo aniquilar al hombre
naranja eso es el lema de victoria
destruir a trump destruir a trump no hay
mensaje no hay proyecto no hay
absolutamente nada por supuesto que el
electorado está donde ese no se va a
motivar entonces el decir
precisamente pasos concretos apoyo a la
fuerza pública para reprimir esta
sublevación que hay en una docena de
ciudades estadounidenses donde quieren
desactivar la fuerza pública
y de nuevo no me crea me miraba en las
víctimas que han llamado porque los
están violando porque les están robando
la tienda porque le están golpeando a un
ser querido y la policía no llega llega
ya cuando se vació el terreno porque
porque esto lo que promueven los
políticos del partido demócrata porque
todos son en ciudades controlados
como bastiones demócrata entonces la
sociedad estadounidense no acepta eso
está mirando eso y separado hasta donde
hasta dónde vamos a llegar entonces la
victoria será puesto a trump en un plato
dorado eso es la realidad y si eso es
emoción pues verá por supuesto es la
emoción de ver una política coherente
que señala a rescatar la democracia
estadounidense defender el estado de
derecho y la libertad y reprimir a esta
fuerza subversiva que no tienen nada que
ver con vidas de minoría ni vida negro
ni nada de eso señor luís montes en
nueva york está que piensa usted mucho
ataque poco mensaje
bueno esto es lo que normalmente nos
tiene acostumbrado trump y los
personeros de trump o los partidarios de
trump me parece que lejos de vaya a
hablar sobre las propuestas es que no ha
habido en una sola propuesta de trompo
en los últimos cuatro años que se ha
hecho en realidad en realidad ha sido
incapaz de construir consenso como llama
el ser presidente y ha sido incapaz hay
que recordar se cuanto hablado con
cuánto sería hablar de la de una
propuesta de infraestructura que iba y
que iba a tratar de pasar tanto por
verdad por el congreso y esto estamos ya
a las puertas de su cuarto de terminar
el cuarto año de ministración y esto
nunca se ha dado
lejos de eso ha tratado de eco como un
como cualquier otro personaje auto
verdad autocrático ha tratado de
gobernar a través de edictos a través de
órdenes ejecutivas y esto obviamente lo
que demuestra es su vaya su carencia de
de poder negociar su carencia él creyó
que iba a poder venir con su mano
matonería a washington a cambiar las
cosas en realidad lejos de limpiar el
pantano como él decía de drenar el
pantano él ha demostrado lo que es
trabajar con trump y lo el pantano que
es y todos los cocodrilos alrededor de
trompe no hay no ha habido básicamente
un año o un desde esta administración en
la que no se ha pasado que no hay bien
un escándalo y todavía lo que falta por
conocerse desde
el nepotismo por parte de la familia de
trump el vaya a toda la gente de roger
son alrededor de él e incluso hasta
generales que han tenido que tenían una
buena hoja de vida es simplemente se
mancharon mancharon esa hoja de vida por
hacer negocios indebidos con control y
esto creo que y toda la gente buena
alrededor de él simplemente ha
renunciado y no quiere nada que ver con
ellos y muchos de ellos han salido
apoyando ya al presidente lo interrumpo
porque en este momento comienzan a
hablar
marc y patrícia mccloskey y ya lo
decíamos ellos son una pareja conocida
de la ciudad de san luis en el estado de
misurí había amenazado con armas a los
manifestantes del movimiento black black
life pero cientos de estadounidenses te
dan consejos en cómo usarlo eso fue lo
que nosotros experimentamos lo que nos
sucedió a nosotros no le puede suceder a
cualquiera de ustedes alrededor de todo
el país y por eso queremos hablarles
esta noche exactamente
ya sea la policía dejando salir a todos
los criminales el mismo día mientras
para que sigan haciendo disturbios
alentando al caos en nuestras calles
parece que los demócratas no ven que el
gobierno debe proteger a los ciudadanos
de los criminales si no defienden a los
criminales de los ciudadanos ni una sola
persona en todos los disturbios que
estaba de nuestra cerca nuestra casa
fueron judicializados a nosotros y nos
acusaron a nosotros con delitos por
atrevernos a proteger nuestro hogar y
sobre todo esto
los activistas que lideraban esta
protesta se pararon afuera de nuestras
casas nos decían no pueden detener esta
revolución
semanas después esa misma persona
activista ganó para ser representante en
la casa representantes y así es cómo
ganar
para nosotros es para ganar una elección
general
será una congresista del primer distrito
de missouri
ellos quieren llegar al congreso
ellos quieren apoderarse quieren tener
el poder este es el partido de joe biden
estas son las personas que estarán a
cargo del futuro y del futuro de sus
hijos
están satisfechos con esparcir el caos
quieren eliminar todos los suburbios
terminando con todas las familias eso
traerá crímenes
el presidente de trump inteligentemente
tras todo esto pero joe biden quiere
volver a esto regresar a esto
así que no haga ningún error sin
importar dónde vivan su familia no
estará segura
si están los demócratas de eeuu si en
este momento se defienden por usted y
por los valores de nuestro país las
manifestantes van a tratar de destruirla
ustedes nos han visto en las pantallas y
no somos las personas que se rinden
gracias a dios yo no son tampoco el
presidente de trump va a defender el
derecho de todos los estadounidenses
para proteger su hogar y sus familias
pero más que eso la visión de tropas de
eeuu es un país en el que tenemos una
oportunidad de trabajar fuertemente y
construir la vida que hemos soñado con
los hijos que pueden ser criados en
grandes escuelas en una comunidad donde
nuestra familia puede jugar en los pasos
de atrás sin ningún miedo e ir a la
iglesia sin vergüenza y expresar sus
creencias sin ninguna retribución trump
trajo la mejor economía que hemos visto
a nuestro país los demócratas nos han
traído nada más que una destrucción
sin mando tenemos bases seguras en
nuestras comunidades no vamos a tener la
libertad para construir un futuro para
nosotros para nuestros hijos y para
nuestro país eso es lo que está en juego
en este país en estas elecciones y por
eso debemos reelegir a tony travers gold
dios los bendiga y dios bendiga al
presidente y dios bendiga a estos
estados unidos
y tenían era la intervención de esta
pareja de esposos marc y patricia
mccloskey ellos son de la ciudad de san
luis en el estado de misurí y se
hicieron conocidos en la unión americana
por esas imágenes que ustedes veían
precisamente durante su intervención por
haber tenido un arma y haber salido a
una manifestación de cerca a su casa con
armas por haberse sentido amenazados por
esta marcha del movimiento black light
matters y ambos son acusados en este
momento de varios delitos graves por ese
hecho en particular vamos a washington
con diana castañeda de nuestra
corresponsal
allí en la capital de eeuu diana tengo
varias preguntas para usted que está
allí al lado de la casa blanca al lado
de donde sucede todos los hechos
políticos interesantes en eeuu mi
primera pregunta es cómo han recibido
esta convocatoria de esta pareja tan
controvertida allí entre los ciudadanos
de estados unidos y luego damos en otros
temas que quiero preguntarse
bueno esto claramente está enviando un
mensaje de la perspectiva y digamos el
plan que tiene el presidente del tranvía
el partido republicano para el 2021 hay
que recordar que durante este año no
solamente la pandemia es uno de los
temas centrales y los planes de
recuperación que habrán en materia de
empleo sino también hay una coyuntura
que desencadenó decenas cientos de
marchas en todo el país tras la muerte
de floyd este hombre afroamericano en
manos de policías blancos que ha
generado digamos reacciones de los dos
lados como este entonces es uno de los
temas que vemos que está siendo presente
en las dos agendas como nunca antes en
las convenciones
si diana uno de los temas importantes
que ha traído esta estas manifestaciones
y este tipo de choques con la policía es
precisamente una posible reforma de la
policía en eeuu
que se sabe al respecto que lo que
propone el presidente trump en torno a
este tema
bueno hay cuatro propuestas principales
que el partido republicano que el
presidente donald trump está lanzando
esta noche para defender a la policía
así lo han nombrado y tiene cuatro
puntos básicos el primero que ha
revelado el partido es la financiación
por completo y contratación de más
agentes de policía para defender a la
nación también aumentar las penas por
agresiones agentes y también que los
tiroteos desde autos sean considerados o
sean procesados como terrorismo
doméstico y la cuarta llevar ante la
justicia a grupos extremistas violentos
como antifa estas son las cuatro
propuestas que hacen parte de lo que
será la plataforma en materia de defensa
de policía del presidente donalson y que
contrastan precisamente con la
plataforma demócrata el presidente
después de estas marchas había anunciado
algunas medidas
sería el comportamiento que debían tener
los departamentos de policía pero el
candidato demócrata byron ha respaldado
la reforma que se está dando al interior
de la cámara de representantes que busca
todo lo contrario que busca aumentar los
fondos federales para que existan más
jueces que juzguen aquellos policías que
se ven envueltos en estos actos
violentos que terminan con la muerte de
personas que pertenecen a minorías
también busca que cuando se ocurran este
tipo de casos los policías no sean
trasladados de un estado al otro así que
hay una gran diferencia en las dos
plataformas que presentan estos dos
partidos vamos a ampliar este este punto
importante con nuestros analistas
invitados más adelante viana para
terminar la última pregunta a los dos
candidatos joe biden y el presidente de
donald trump que busca la reelección han
estado muy activos en las redes sociales
y han estado como partido de tenis
lanzándose la pelota uno al otro hace
unos minutos joe biden él le respondió a
donald trump en torno al tema del hobbit
y 9 que también es un punto de coyuntura
importante
y responsabilizándolo de lo que está
sucediendo y de esta cantidad de casos
confirmados en la unión americana
si así lo hace este tuit con un gráfico
animado desde cuándo comenzó la pandemia
y cómo se registró el incremento de
casos en los eeuu hasta llegar a ser el
país con más casos así que estamos
viendo también esto lo vimos durante la
convención demócrata como el presidente
de donald trump decidía hablar cuando
vaivén tenía que dar su discurso y ahora
vemos a baile en las redes sociales pues
responsabilizando a trump sobre esta
pandemia y el manejo que ha dado y
también pues la crisis económica que
enfrentan millones de personas en los
eeuu 40 millones de personas solicitando
subsidios de desempleo y precisamente el
presidente de alstom va a anunciar tres
puntos importantes de lo que será su
plataforma o plan de recuperación para
la pandemia que como mencionaba incluyen
la vacuna para final de este año volver
a la normalidad en el 2021 y proveer a
los trabajadores esenciales de los
hospitales de todo lo que necesiten para
hacer frente a la pandemia y tener
fondos
a prevenir una futura pandemia llena
gracias por aclararnos estos puntos a
analizar para nosotros y para nuestra
teleaudiencia estos puntos importantes
de esta convención de republicana en la
ciudad de charlotte él le pregunto ahora
a mamen sal a nuestra corresponsable en
la ciudad de nueva york ya que estamos
tocando el tema de la pandemia del cob y
19 porque nueva york que fue el foco
inicial fue la ciudad en donde más casos
se presentaron en los primeros meses de
la pandemia allí en eeuu este tema le
cobrará un poco al presidente trump a
algunos votos allí en la ciudad de nueva
york que es un importante centro de
votación dado a que hay personas de
todas las etnias de todas las razas de
todos los países congregados en una sola
ciudad
por supuesto de hecho ya lo vimos que el
tema como bien decía es el tema de la
pandemia también ha estado también ha
estado en el centro de todos los debates
y por supuesto estuvo también en el
centro de la convención demócrata a la
semana pasada y de hecho yo wyden en su
discurso puso encima de la mesa
soluciones desde el día uno que sí
chicos y finalmente consigue llegar a la
casa blanca y está interesante también
porque por mucho que a los oradores
republicanos en esta convención hayan
intentado apuntar a que donald trump en
el fondo no lo ha hecho trama lo que es
cierto es que en estos momentos
superamos ya los 177 mil fallecidos y
cinco millones y cinco millones y medio
más de cinco millones y medio de
contagiados y eso por supuesto ha
impactado mucho en la población y en el
voto tenemos que tener en cuenta que
donald trump en estos meses ha perdido
el apoyo de los votantes mayores los
votantes mayores de 65 años que han
visto que un presidente que su
presidente quizá ha apostado más por la
economía que por su propia salud y esto
es un voto que está perdiendo donald
trump
bastante importante porque precisamente
fue el que le dio la victoria en el 2016
así que va a ser un tema que desde luego
van a tener que tratar de manera muy
delicada y sobre todo con unas cifras
encima de la mesa que no les favorecen
nada como decía es nueva york si fue el
estado más castigado pero ahora mismo en
estos momentos parece que estamos que
somos uno de los mejores estados de los
mejores de todos los 50 estados que está
gestionando esta crisis llevamos 16 días
en nueva york con un porcentaje de
infección por debajo del 1 por ciento y
el sábado tuvimos 24 horas sin que
muriera una persona por kobe 19 que
teniendo en cuenta cómo golpeó y castigó
el coronavirus a este estado desde luego
es todo un logro es todo un logro y son
cifras alentadoras mamen después del
panorama que tuve esa ciudad como tuvo
que enfrentar la ciudad de nueva york
este problema de la pandemia y sobre
todo la situación en los barrios más
pobres que en la mayoría de ellos son
habitados por migrantes latinoamericanos
asiáticos y africanos que han sido los
más vulnerables
a esta pandemia de 1.019 ahora el foco
está en arizona en texas en florida y
california que son los que están
haciendo ahora frente a unos rebrotes
importantes el señor julio chilling en
la ciudad de miami precisamente allí
donde está ahora el foco de la pandemia
del cob y 19 es uno de los puntos
críticos en la unión americana el tema
de la pandemia le puede pasar factura al
presidente de donald trump o le puede
costar algunos votos en esta reelección
pero realmente él lo que estamos
escuchando o sea como que esto se trata
de escoger entre la vida y la economía o
sea que es una forma de presentarla
totalmente
inaceptable porque sin economía no hay
para pagar las máscaras no hay para
buscar una vacuna no hay para resolver
de manera de que esto hay que mirarlo de
una forma integrador la verdad porque
hay muertes por personas que no se están
haciendo con los copias porque no están
haciendo tratamientos de cáncer en fin
es una política integradora es mucho más
eficaz porque si queremos a ciencia
cierta terminar con los accidentes de
automóvil vamos a ilegalizar que se
maneje si no queremos que nadie se muere
un choque de avión
vamos a ilegalizar los vuelos aéreos
entonces
eso es una política absurda decir que se
entre una cosa o la otra en cuanto a la
comparación entre la florida por ejemplo
y nueva york
ahí lo importante de ver es cuántas
personas se están muriendo y el nivel de
supervivencia en la florida es
formidable comparada con la política de
negligencia que se quedó en nueva york'
y cuando hablamos de el récord del
presidente del chrome en cuanto a esto a
finales de enero con sólo seis personas
66 personas contagiadas cerró los vuelos
con china y a los pocos días lo cerró
con europa y mientras tanto que estaban
haciendo los demócratas teniendo
audiencias para acusar a la
administración from desert xenofóbico de
ser racista busquen los vídeos desde
bailén diciendo los racistas que strong
por cerrar los vuelos de china es una
vergüenza que la semana pasada el
partido demócrata no hizo ninguna
mención del culpable porque esta
pandemia y estos muertos tienen nombre y
apellido y es china comunista que ocultó
y le mintió a la comunidad internacional
sobre lo que estaba ocurriendo
esto se puede haber evitado y no les
importa un bledo el partido demócrata en
parte está demostrando una complicidad
con ese fenómeno al querer ocultar y
culpar de todo al presidente de chrome
cuando ellos promovían políticas que
precisamente como que fueran al barrio
chino de san francisco o al barrio chino
en nueva york eso lo promovieron
políticos demócratas de una manera
negligente y la verdad quiere echar la
culpa trump señor montes algo que decir
al respecto
bueno típico republicano que habla de
responsabilidad personal y son incapaces
de tomar esa responsabilidad personal
obviamente esto tiene un líder lo decía
estirar las decisiones para en ese
escritorio de la de la oficina oval y el
responsable de esta crisis el
responsable de no poner un plan nacional
de para pruebas para test y para el de
no proveer a los a los estados y no ni
coordinar con los estados de manera
debida una respuesta integral a este a
este a este virus
es precisamente tiene un nombre y un
apellido se llama donald trump él es el
responsable de que 170 mil personas de
177 mil personas estén ahora infectadas
de kobe él es el responsable de perdón
muertas por kobe él es el responsable de
que no se tenga en el que muchas de las
de las personas en la primera línea como
fueron los
bomberos los técnicos de emergencia las
enfermeras los doctores no tuvieran sps
material de necesario para protección
personal para poder defender esto es una
vergüenza que trump estando a la
liderazgo y siendo él el líder del mundo
occidental y del y del mundo parece para
para eso simplemente este atrás de
países con mucho menos recursos que sí
que han tenido una respuesta más certera
una respuesta con mucha más sensatez que
la que verdad este inepto de trump a
verdaderamente hecho
señor carlos arias en la ciudad de
bogotá yo supongo que para usted el tema
de la pandemia del cobi 19 ha sido un
importante punto de análisis en cuanto
al manejo que le han tenido que dar los
gobiernos de los diferentes países
analizar por ejemplo cómo ha sido la
entrega la información como ha sido la
claridad de los mensajes en el caso de
la casa blanca de trump que vimos casos
incluso hasta de fake news diciéndoles
que podrían tomarse algunos químicos
para ser inmunes al al al virus
señalando constantemente a china dando
prioridad a temas económicos
porque pues sea su prioridad de gobierno
y entregando en algunos casos
información equivocada y como ya lo
decíamos fake news qué análisis hace
usted de esa parte de comunicaciones y
de entrega de información a los
ciudadanos por parte de trump
bueno tenemos hay un inconveniente con
el audio de nuestro invitado carlos
arias que es estratega en materia de
comunicación política y nos estaba
haciendo un banal
un análisis un balance de lo que puede
ser considerado como una gestión a buena
o mala por parte del presidente donald
trump en torno al tema de la pandemia de
kobe 19 eeuu como lo sabemos es el país
con la mayor cantidad de casos ya no lo
decidan nuestros invitados y nuestros
corresponsales desde la ciudad de
washington y desde la ciudad de nueva
york les confirmo en unos minutos estará
hablando y estaremos oyendo las palabras
de nikki haley a la embajadora de eeuu
ante el organismo de las naciones unidas
y estaremos oyendo su intervención que
es una de las esperadas para esta noche
esta primera noche de tierra de promesas
como se ha denominado esta primera noche
de la convención republicana retomamos
entonces la comunicación con carlos
adelante ahora sí lo vimos fuerte y
claro bien
yo no puedo dejar de pasar todo lo que
han dicho los colegas hoy de panel y de
análisis
entonces quiero hacer tres observaciones
rápidamente después de la convención
demócrata y recientemente la prensa ha
empezado a salir varios números y número
muy importante real de lo que se está
diciendo es que muchos norteamericanos
incluso demócratas están diciendo que es
entre comillas aceptable del número de
muertos que hoy hoy llevan los eeuu y es
entre comillas es un no es un dato menor
porque entre comillas empieza a validar
lo que es el saldo social
lamentablemente y es muy fuerte decirlo
pero entre los ciudadanos empiezan a ver
ese digamos ese tipo de compensaciones
de bueno no fueron tantos para hacer
mucho más claro y dos muy muy importante
al tir de orientar a responder esa
pregunta que me hacía
más allá de la indignación que pueda
generar los diferentes discursos y las
técnicas de donald trump que va a ser el
partido demócrata en términos
estratégicos porque es que ya está claro
que las emociones son los que los que
detonan el voto ya está claro que donald
trump es el rey de las emociones y que
byd en poco o nada de emoción a sí
entonces más allá de indignarse que
puede hacer en términos estratégicos
reales para convencer para persuadir
para lograr desatar esa polarización que
genera donald trump para poder llamar al
voto de ese voto neutral que está entre
los republicanos y los demócratas y
ahora bien entrando ya a responder el
tema de las pequeños y básicamente el
tema de 'the news' es algo que toma que
toca la regulación en comunicación en
redes sociales no puede ser posible que
plataformas como twitter y facebook
sigan permitiendo que independientemente
de la autoridad y la jerarquía que tenga
un jefe de gobierno independientemente
del país se sigan presentando este tipo
de anomalías y este tipo de mentiras que
más allá de manipular a la opinión
pública
ocasiona graves casos de salud como el
que se que se causó en guatemala como se
causó en colombia en cali y como se
causó en eeuu con personas que
deliberadamente siguieron las
recomendaciones de una persona que no
sabe del tema siempre dígame lógicos ni
mucho tema ni mucho menos este tema de
salud imagino que usted ha tenido
muchísimas aristas para analizar en
torno a este tema de la pandemia no
solamente en eeuu sino de otros países
de américa latina y bueno del mundo
entero sobre la forma en que se ha
comunicado y se ha manejado cree usted
que entonces el tema de la pandemia va a
ser central va a ser uno de estos ejes
principales o tratarán de disminuirlo y
mitigar lo un poco enfocarlo más en el
tema económico mire eso que usted acaba
de preguntar y qué pena que haga recoger
este cliché de qué buena pregunta es muy
buena pregunta porque básicamente en
términos de la construcción del lenguaje
y la construcción persuasiva del
discurso en análisis de discurso que es
psicología política cuando usted siembra
temor recoge seguridad entonces cuando
usted construye un mensaje de temor
alrededor de la pandemia alrededor de la
crisis económica alrededor de américa
way the game
que nos van a quitar nuestro espacio los
migrantes seguramente vamos a empezar a
recoger seguridad más adelante
punto importante para aclarar y punto
importante de cara a estas votaciones
eso puede persuadir a muchos de los
votantes a muchos de los que están allí
sobre todo en estas elecciones en la que
entran a votar muchísimos
latinoamericanos particularmente de
venezuela que han emigrado a eeuu y ya
después de haber recibido en este país
varios años ya tienen derecho a votar
porque se han convertido en ciudadanos
de la palabra a julio chilling en miami
adelante
muchas gracias veras y realmente para mí
un privilegio estar la minoría no sólo
por los demócratas declarados de
movilidad o los demócratas disfrazados
de nuevo ser los primeros hablan de
facebook de facebook se refieren a que a
cnn msn bc o a quien se refieren a que
no está porque lo dijo que no están
censurando al presidente sin embargo
twitter sin embargo twitter que permite
que china que la dictadura de los a esto
lo digan lo que quieran esperar
realmente
el partidismo es aceptable y este debate
se basa en eso pero quitemos disfraz de
ser imparcial por favor porque es o sea
está faltando respeto uno mismo y repito
aunque esto leyera la sensibilidad del
señor james no perdiéndole lo interrumpo
un momento me piden que me conecte en
este momento a charlotte para ver qué es
lo que está pasando en este momento allí
vamos a escuchar lo que sucede en la
convención en este momento
estuve en síria por 63 días retenido
creo que hablo por todos detenidos y
rehenes estoy bastante agradecido por
regresar a casa me salgo gracias por la
invitación y la oportunidad de estar
aquí
particularmente el pastor bryant ha sido
de gran ayuda a mi familia gracias por
promocionarlo a él gracias por estar
aquí
te trajimos de vuelta los trajimos a
todos de vuelta y estamos trabajando
para atraer a otros más mi nombre es
michael una vez más es un honor estar
aquí un honor conocerlo en persona
básicamente lo que sucedió conmigo fue
que trabajé a irán y hubo una trampa y
estuve detenido pase por mucho en el
sistema de justicia iraní
pero lo que usted hizo puede lograr
sacarme de allá en un tiempo récord fue
increíble muchas gracias
por favor mi nombre es yo soy mi esposa
mis turismos rehenes en venezuela por 2
años
y usted nos ayuda a salir de allá
y fue un gran honor poder conocerlo
cuando regresábamos recordamos que mucha
gente me preguntó cómo era conocer al
presidente truco
yo estaba impresionada me habían
liberado después de dos años y estaba
saludando al presidente de la oficina
ahora así que es bueno estar de vuelta
haya sido increíble volver y ayudar a la
gente que ha experimentado lo mismo
hemos empezado una familia y nosotros
pudimos hacer algo por estados y creo
que por varios estadounidenses fue un
periodo bastante hostil
apreciamos bastante a todos los que
trabajaron con nosotros para que
lograron lograron volver
así que saludos a todos en youtube
porque son grandes personas
felicitaciones muchas gracias
estuve limpia no iba a ir a india iba de
india nepal donde trabajan los últimos
18 años pero nombre de mi familia y de
mi quiero agradecer el presidente trompo
pues por traernos de vuelta el momento
más oscuro de todo nuestro tiempo juntos
llegó su carta él nos dio paz y
esperanza y mientras más gente se veía
involucrada al embajador en india todo
nos llenó de esperanza estudia y los
últimos cuatro meses desde que lo
logramos volver planeaban tenerme de 3 a
5 años los cargos eran de 3 a 5 años si
hacer aclaró luego se inventaron nuevos
cargos que son 7 años usted respondió
bastante a nuestro requerimiento lo
apreciamos gracias a ustedes por estar
con nosotros queremos otras más personas
de vuelta y volverán de regreso pronto
muchas gracias grandes historias
testimonios de ciudadanos
estadounidenses ahí lo teníamos aquí en
las pantallas de france 24 en directo
desde la ciudad de charlotte en carolina
del norte con la traducción del aura
garzón del equipo de france 24 el señor
schilling retomo con usted le pido
disculpas por haber interrumpido su
intervención pero era necesario darle
paso a este tipo de testimonios que
tienen lugar en esta convención adelante
con lo que usted estaba contándonos con
gusto yo soy el primero que tengo gran
placer en ceder el espacio para el
presidente y le agradezco ustedes por
estar ocurriendo mira el sinn sin ánimo
de ofender a nadie pero es es un
simplismo realmente irresponsable si
queremos vencer
este este mal que vino de china
comunista
hay que tener una economía hay que tener
una economía para la asistencia social
para buscar la vacuna para precisamente
proveer y no es continuar todos los
mecanismos necesarios para mantener la
sociedad sana y salva que se padece de
otras cosas depresión enfermedades que
no se pueden paralizar un país con fin
de llegar al número cero que nadie se
muera del coronavirus porque de nuevo
que a usar los ejemplos de que cada cosa
si queremos evitar que nadie se muera de
un auto pues legalicemos los autos
entonces es importante mirar esto de una
forma integradora en cuanto a el hc
por favor que están criticando al
presidente por no estar recomiendo estar
recomendando eso pues entonces porque no
está calificado pues tampoco está
calificado otras personas como estamos
escuchando desacreditando algo que sí le
ha funcionado a determinadas personas es
si hay medicamentos que funcionan con
personas y otros que no entonces
es algo entre el paciente y el médico
sin embargo se ha tomado una visión
unísono en cuanto a la política que
tomar se han ilegalizado la prescripción
de ciertos medicamentos atando los
brazos de los médicos hay persecución
legal contra médicos que consideran
basado en su experiencia empírica de que
son medicamentos como el htc el htc
perdón que si funciona en tratar
determinados casos el coronavirus no
estamos diciendo que es la vacuna no lo
esté y no hay ni siquiera vacuna para el
sida entonces espero hablar de una
manera como si tienen el monopolio de la
verdad la verdad en cuanto a determinada
visión médica es un grave error al
contrario el método científico invita
una visión mucho más panorámica
mamen sala en la ciudad de nueva york
que hablando de lo que puede dejar esta
pandemia ya nueva york comienza a dar
algunos números positivos y que alienta
un poco de cara a esa recuperación
cuáles son entonces esas preferencias
que podría necesitar este estado y esta
ciudad después de el embate de la
pandemia del que todavía se está
tratando de recuperar no cantemos
todavía victoria pero cuáles serían esas
necesidades que le reclaman los
neoyorquinos al gobierno de donald trump
sí pues en estos momentos santiago lo
más importante y algo que ha dejado muy
claro el gobernador del estado de nueva
york andrew cómo es que una solución
pasa por testear por realizar pruebas de
covite al mayor número de población
posible para localizar los casos
positivos a aislarlos y evitar que el
virus se siga expandiendo es muy
importante también y muy interesante
esto que decíamos anteriormente como
este virus se ha cebado sobre todo con
las poblaciones con las con los grupos
minoritarios como pueden ser latinos y
afroamericanos precisamente latinos es
lo que estamos viendo una falta de
presencia en esta convención unos
latinos que en teoría tan debería
apostar por convencer el día 3 de
noviembre y que además de haber estado
muy castigados por el coronavirus
también ha estado han estado muy
castigados por la crisis económica que
ha seguido el coronavirus entonces dada
la situación se está echando de menos
escuchar voces de representantes pues
hispanos no aquí en nueva york otra cosa
que hace falta es ese control que se
está llevando a cabo está
en las entradas al estado como sabéis es
obligatoria una cuarentena de 14 días
así procede de uno de los estados más
afectados en estos momentos de esta
manera se está intentando controlar sí
que hemos de decir que es verdad que
estamos en una situación en la que no es
del todo real porque seguimos con los
restaurantes interior en la parte
interior del restaurante continúa estar
estando cerrada a los gimnasios
continúan cerrados a los cines continúan
cerrados todavía no hemos llegado a una
situación de normalidad pero mientras
tanto sí que es verdad que se está
pudiendo contener esa expansión del
virus diana en la capital de eeuu en
washington allí los ciudadanos la
comunidad en general allí también hay un
componente hispano importante sabemos
que no es mucho la preferencia o el
público objetivo al que le apuesta la
campaña de trump y es algo que vimos en
la campaña pasada pero que le reclaman
al presidente de eeuu allí
así es y digamos que tanto en la capital
de los eeuu como en estados aledaños
como maryland y virginia hay una gran
población hispana que se ha visto muy
afectada por la crisis y la razón por la
que se ha visto afectada es porque estos
beneficios que entregó el presidente de
unalt son durante la pandemia beneficios
como por ejemplo los cheques por 1.200
dólares que envió a las familias
con el nombre de el cheque del
presidente de donald trump beneficios en
materia de desempleo no aplicaban para
aquellas personas que no tuvieran un
estatus legal en los estados unidos
afectando considerablemente a la
población hispana y a otro tipo de
grupos de inmigrantes y esto pues generó
también una discusión entre los
gobiernos estatales y el gobierno
federal sobre que tantos beneficios se
podía dar o no y sobre todo el rechazo
por parte de organizaciones que
defienden los derechos de los
inmigrantes
considerar que una pandemia no
discrimina y por lo tanto cualquier
persona debería recibir ayuda por parte
del gobierno federal y es uno de los
temas digamos más controversiales que
les reclaman los latinos al presidente
de sobre todo porque hay que explicar
que hay una gran cantidad de familias
mixtas es decir que por ejemplo muchos
padres llegaron siendo indocumentados a
los eeuu pero sus hijos son ciudadanos y
pueden votar entonces esto
definitivamente tendrá importancia en la
decisión que tomen algunos de los
latinos al momento de votar pero también
tiene importancia ya que el presidente
de donald trump vuelve a reafirmar en su
agenda y en sus propuestas que tiene
para esta noche y para esta convención
que no va a permitir que beneficios
federales lleguen a personas que no
tengan un estatus legal es decir que no
sean residentes o ciudadanos de los
estados unidos-ghana siempre este ha
sido un tema controversial desde el
punto de vista
de derechos ha sido criticado por
algunas organizaciones este manejo que
le ha dado el presidente de trump a
mantenerse a raya con el tema de los
migrantes y con las personas que están
en eeuu que como usted dice no tienen un
estatus legal pero están allí en eeuu
desde hace varios años y algunas
autoridades les daban acceso a algunos
beneficios con el presidente trump a
algunas de estas de estos aspectos han
cambiado y ha generado como hemos visto
ese rifirrafe con el gobierno de mexico
y con los gobiernos del triángulo del
norte en centroamérica vamos a charlotte
en este momento interviene nicky reilly
ex embajadora de eeuu ante la onu
escuchemos a los republicanos frente voy
a comenzar con una pequeña historia es
acerca de una embajadora de las naciones
unidas y de un discurso que ya vio en
esta convención y pidió por la
reelección del presidente start y llamó
a su
es embajadora dijo que los demócratas
siempre cumplan a eeuu primero el año
las palabras del embajador son reales
hoy en día hay delitos demócratas aún
culpa en eeuu primero yo no siempre
apuesto eeuu primero y él ha ganado
cuatro años más como presidente y fue un
honor de la vida servir como la
embajadora de eeuu en las naciones
unidas así que las naciones unidas es un
lugar donde los dictadores asesinos y
ladrones denuncian a estados unidos y
luego demandan que nosotros les paguemos
sus cuentas reciente trump le puso fin a
todo eso con su liderazgo nosotros
hicimos lo que barack obama joe biden se
negaron a hacer
defendimos a eeuu y nos defendimos de
nuestros enemigos
obama y biden dejan que corea del norte
amenazara eeuu
el presidente trump rechazó esa
debilidad y pasamos las sanciones más
difíciles en la historia a corea del
norte
obama y biden dejaron que se salieran
con los asesinatos y les enviaran dinero
el presidente trompo rompió con el
acuerdo iraní
el presidente se movió nuestra embajada
a jerusalén y cuando las naciones unides
nosotros fue orgullosos declarar el veto
de eeuu en esa votación
es bueno para iraní para crisis bueno
para la china
y quiere que eeuu siempre se disculpe y
abandonen nuestros valores
donald trump s ni fuerte con china acabó
con isis y ganó y le dice al mundo lo
que necesita escuchar
en nuestro hogar el presidente es la
opción correcta para la economía y los
trabajos mientras que yo bailé en lo que
ha hecho es retrasar a eeuu
yo era gobernadora de carolina del sur
en las manufacturas llegaron a todas
partes del mundo creando miles de
trabajos para los estadounidenses mucha
gente
llamaban caroline al sur como las
bestias
nosotros reducimos los impuestos ellos
lo aumentaron y nosotros cuando nosotros
hicimos buenos trabajos creamos los
trabajos vice de obama nos demandaron yo
me defendí y ellos se rindieron
bailén jarvis una administración de ebay
de mijares sería mucho peor la última
vez
el jefe de biden era obama parecería
sanders pelosi y su cuadrilla ellos se
basan en el socialismo y sabemos que el
socialismo ha fallado en todas partes
ellos quieren decirle a eeuu cómo vivir
como pensar y quieren que el gobierno se
encargue de la salud
quieren destruir millones de trabajos
quieren una granja cobra una cantidad de
impuestos
socialista-radical de ellos sería un
error
el presidente trompo libera una nueva
era antes de que china no saliera el
coronavirus nosotros estábamos rompiendo
los récords económicos la pandemia nos
ha un poco pero no por mucho
tiempo el presidente trump
va a lograr volverla a resurgir hay un
área muy importante donde nuestro
presidente es lo correcto él sabe
en mucho del partido democrático es
común decir que eeuu es racista eso es
una mentira eeuu no es un país racista
esto es personal para mí
yo soy la hija de inmigrantes de la
india
mi padre usa un turbante mi madre nos
avanzar y yo
era una pequeña niña y nos enfrentamos a
discriminación pero mis padres nunca se
dieron ante el odio mi madre hizo un
negocio exitoso mi padre fue profesor en
una escuela
y me escogieron a mí como la gobernadora
primera mujer gobernadora y de la
minoría de eeuu es un trabajo en
progreso
hay que seguir con este progreso hay que
hacerla más libre y mejor para todo el
mundo y más justa es por eso que es muy
triste ver al partido demócrata ser
hacerse los ciegos frente a los
disturbios y las protestas
es claro que nosotros valoramos a todas
las personas incluso los afro
descendientes de descendientes incluso
los policías afrodescendientes a todos
los trabajadores y empresarios
afrodescendientes también las mujeres
los niños afrodescendientes también sus
vidas
son importantes
no debe ser así
así no eras de 5 años en carolina del
sur
nuestro estado se enfrentó frente al mar
una persona entró en un estudio de
biblia 12 personas rezaron con él por
una hora él empezó luego a disparar
después de esa tragedia
no nos pusimos una en contra de otros
nos unimos blancos y negros demócratas y
republicanos tomamos las decisiones
difíciles para poder sanar y avanzar de
una forma pacífica pacífica y respeto' y
de manera respetuosa y eso nos da
esperanza ahora eeuu no es perfecto pero
los principales que tenemos son
perfectos si hay algo que he aprendido
es que nuestro peor día nosotros somos
bendecidos por vivir en eeuu es tiempo
de mantener estado en bendición para el
resto de las generaciones este
presidente y este partido están
comprometidos con esta tarea buscamos
una nación que resurge junta y no que
cae en la energía
sabemos que la única forma de
sobreponernos a los retos es darle la
bienvenida a las fortalezas de eeuu
estamos buscando donde un futuro
brillante donde todas las personas y
todos niños van a una buena escuela
donde viven en una comunidad segura con
buenos trabajos donde los empresarios y
emprendedores pueden buscar sus sueños
donde cualquier soñador puede trabajar y
donde todas las vidas son protegidas
cualquier niña y niño mujer y hombre de
cualquier religión y raza para tener la
mejor oportunidad y la mejor el mejor
tipo de vida en esta elección debemos
elegir al único candidato que ha tenido
y que va a continuar
liderando esta visión el presidente
camps y el vicepresidente page tienen mi
apoyo y eeuu tienen nuestras promesas
vamos a construir el progreso nuestro
pasado y continuar
haciendo las promesas del futuro
y buscando la reelección de donald trump
gracias y que dios siempre bendiga a
estados unidos
[Música]
intervención de la ex embajadora de eeuu
en la organización de las naciones
unidas en la ciudad de nueva york la
señora nicky reilly haciendo un balance
tocando temas de la realidad
internacional haciendo un balance de la
gestión del presidente de donald trump
en torno a estos temas vamos de nuevo a
charlotte en este momento interviene
donald trump
de la historia eeuu
para hablar de este país que tanto
amamos esta tierra de promesas y
oportunidad de héroes y de grandeza
hace unos meses atrás estamos viendo el
sueño eeuu convertirse en realidad
para muchos de los ciudadanos
la mayor extracción económica de la
historia de eeuu la menor tasa de
desempleo en la historia es para
hispanoamericanos afroamericanos y las
mujeres y casi para todo otros grupos
demográficos luego vimos
el virus que llegó de china al
presidente decidió prohibir los viajes
de china joe biden y sus aliados
democráticos llevaron a mi padre como un
ser xenófobo y racista
afortunadamente mientras el virus empezó
a esparcir presidente actuó rápidamente
y entregó los respiradores a los
hospitales que necesitaban y él vivió al
sector privado para que ayudara en este
nuevo reto hay una luz al final del
túnel
las políticas de vaivén de izquierda
radical está diciendo que quiere volver
a cerrar el país esto es una locura los
demócratas dicen que son para los
trabajadores pero no empezó a toda la
pandemia en tratar de subir los
impuestos y luego quieren atacar a mi
padre por suspender los pagos a los
trabajadores de clase media si lo
piensan
joe biden toda la plataforma económica
está diseñada para destruir a los
trabajadores
por el apoyo por el chip y adiós a los
trabajos de manufactura
es tan débil ante china que el partido
comunista de china favorece bien porque
sabe que nos va a debilitar a nivel
mundial
quiere que venga más inmigrantes
ilegales para tomar trabajos
él ha dicho que quiere repeler los
recorte de los impuestos que ha sido el
mayor en nuestro país luego de la lenta
y el lento crecimiento de obama y bailén
en las políticas de champ han sido como
un cohete creciendo vaivén así ha
prometido sacar ese dinero de su
bolsillo y mantenerlo
él ha trabajado siempre de vez en cuando
para ser presidente luego desaparece y
no hace mucho
inforó así que si buscan experiencia
busquen al hombre que ha dicho lo que la
administración obama y bailén nunca
lograron y construir la economía más
grande que nuestro país ha visto el
presidente camps lo volverás
vamos a hacer más fuerte que nunca
porque cuando nos enfocamos en ello no
hay ningún obstáculo que ningún
estadounidense puede sobrepasar el
pistón excepto que hay una diferencia
esta vez en el pasado y los dos partidos
creyeron en lo bueno de eeuu estábamos
de acuerdo en lo que queríamos pero no
estamos en desacuerdo en cómo lo
lograríamos esta vez el partido se va
está atacando las fundaciones y las
bases de eeuu la libertad de religión la
libertad de expresar de expresión
a nuestros fundadores creyeron que no
era más importante que proteger nuestro
derecho para pensar por nosotros mismos
ahora a la izquierda lo que están
tratando es de eliminar todo eso no
parecen entender este principio para
poder mejorar el futuro debemos aprender
de nuestro pasado no borrar nuestro
pasado así que no vamos a destruir
monumentos y olvidar a las personas que
construyeron nuestro país en cambio
vamos a aprender de nuestro pasado para
no repetir los errores y vamos a
trabajar para mejorar la vida de todos
los estadounidenses joe biden y la
izquierda radical ahora vienen por
nuestra libertad de expresión si ellos
logran lo que quieren no va a ser la el
si la mayoría del silencio si no la
mayoría va a ser silenciado esto debe
tenerse la libertad de expresión debe
era un valor fundamental ahora partido
republicano es el lugar de la libertad
de expresión donde cualquiera
de hablar y puede hacer que sus ideas y
las mejores ganen las personas con fe
están bajo ataques no pueden ir a las
iglesias pero el caos en las calles
puede pasar es como si estas elecciones
de la iglesia el colegio las comunidades
contra el vandalismo las protestas
disfrutaste o como dice vaivén y sus
aliados las protestas pacíficas
los pequeños gobiernos en eeuu la
mayoría y minorías está han sido
demolidos por ahora
las protestas dicen que es un enero del
amor un verano del amor
todos los eeuu estadunidenses deben
vivir sin miedo en las comunidades y en
sus hogares todas las mujeres y los
hombres fueron creados iguales y fueran
y deben ser tratados bajo la ley por eso
debemos terminar con el racismo y
asegurarnos que cualquier policía que
abusa de su poder tiene que responder
ante la justicia
fue horrible policía para cortar hasta
estar de acuerdo en esto
ellos merecen nuestra presión nuestro
porqué no sin importar lo que dicen los
demócratas usted y yo sabemos cuando lo
llamamos al 911
no queremos que vaya a un buzón de
mensajes desmantele desmantelar la
policía no es la opción
no podemos tener nada sin la seguridad y
la protección
no podemos ver si los niños pueden jugar
en sus
barrios y dormir tranquilamente en sus
camas pero la protección y la seguridad
son el comienzo y la tierra de trump es
un lugar de promesas de libertad yo pude
crecer en una familia donde me podían
otorgar la mejor educación en las dos
mejores universidades pero esto debería
ser accesible para todo el mundo y por
eso mis padres dice que él ha pedido que
la educación accesible es un tema clave
para todo el tiempo es inaceptable que
afroamericanos e hispanoamericanos estén
en malas escuelas solo porque así es y
no lo va a permitir
si los demócratas van deberían ayudar a
las minorías
deberían dejar elegir que sus padres
elijan cuáles son las mejores escuelas
para que sus hijos vayan de policía
ellos deberían apoyar a los policías que
protegen nuestros barrios debería
aprender a negociar
que pongan a los intereses de eeuu
primero y terminar estas guerras y
terminar años de enviar a nuestros
jóvenes para solucionar los problemas
que ellos mismos crean
in spain in itinere cities
en otras palabras si los demócratas
les importaran las personas de eeuu
harían exactamente lo que estarías lo
que está haciendo el presidente de
donald trump eeuu el país más grande del
mundo pero mi padre la visión de mi
padre y vendedor es que nosotros siempre
podemos hacer mucho mejor imagínense lo
que lo que puede tener un gran trabajo o
un gran hogar una gran familia usted lo
puede tener imagínense el país en el que
quiere vivir donde hay oportunidades
igualitarias donde hay trabajos bien
pagos y usted puede tener eso imagínense
un mundo donde la maldad del comunismo y
es lo mismo no tienen la oportunidad de
crecer donde los héroes son celebrados y
los buenos ganan usted puede tener eso
esa es la vida este es el país este es
el mundo que donald trump y el partido
republicano quieren y sí
puede tenerlo porque hay la diferencia
de joe biden y de la izquierda a radicar
nuestro partido está abierto para todo
el mundo que comienza rechazando a todos
los radicales y dándole bienvenida a los
hombres que representan un futuro
lindo para todos nosotros pues empieza
como donald trump como presidente de
eeuu carl pues gracias y que dios
bendiga a estados unidos
donald trump juniors hijo del presidente
de donald trump haciendo su intervención
en esta primera noche de la convención
republicana hablo de diferentes temas
comenzó hablando del tema económico la
gran expansión económica que tenía eeuu
hasta el inicio de la pandemia del cob y
19 las altas tasas de empleo que estaba
presentando el país y cómo puede llegar
a hacer esa reconstrucción económica de
cara a ofrecerle mejores garantías a los
ciudadanos que están en la unión
americana mejores beneficios en
educación en acceso a universidades en
salud también hablo de las reacciones
que tuvo el gobierno a lo largo de estos
meses de pandemia que fue criticado por
diferentes sectores de los demócratas
críticas que él devolvió en este
discurso en esta intervención como
orador de esta primera noche de la
convención republicana habló del
comercio de esos acuerdos alcanzados
particularmente con méxico y canadá para
hacer esa renovación del acuerdo
comercial que tenía
los tres países una renovación que a
méxico le costó mucho su negociación
pero que finalmente llegó a un puerto de
acuerdo con beneficios o no para los
tres países todos tuvieron que hacer
algún punto tanto canadá como estados
unidos o méxico en este punto y también
ese acuerdo recientemente alcanzado con
china que ya de hecho es noticia en este
momento de que ambos países han
calificado como exitoso ese acuerdo
comercial que estaban pendientes de
firmar ambos países para reactivar y
bajar un poco la atención entre beijing
y washington reiteró el mensaje de la
noche eeuu una tierra de promesas una
tierra de garantías para los ciudadanos
estadounidenses garantías educativas
garantías de salud y sobre todo
garantías de seguridad vamos a conversar
con el señor julio schilling hacer un
poco de balance sobre esta intervención
de nicky reilly y de donald trump júnior
mientras esperamos la intervención de
los siguientes invitados señor si leen
sus impresiones
como amenazante hago cualquier similitud
en las palabras del embajador hayley y
el hijo del presidente con lo que es he
pronunciado aquí pues tal vez estaban
escuchando el programa de france 24 y de
ahí puede derivar algunas similitudes en
los conceptos pero fueron dos grandes
discursos y realmente mira nos deja ver
y tengo que traer a colación ciertas
cosas por ejemplo de pretender dar
elección en el caso de nueva york la
verdad cuando de los 32 mil muertos 4500
fue precisamente por una firma directiva
del gobernador cuomo o sea es un estado
que tiene una estampida de sus
ciudadanos casi un estado policiaco
persiguiendo a personas que no tienen
máscara en fin nuevo modelo de éxito el
discurso de el presidente el del hijo
del presidente por muy importante
destacar en los logros económicos
tenemos que entender que los tres años y
medio un crecimiento
la bolsa del 52% cuando hablamos del
dado donde estamos hablando de en efecto
a la maquinaria económica estadounidense
que si llego a los que menos tienen las
minorías fueron los que más se
beneficiaron como el resaltó los
ciudadanos negros e hispanos
estadounidenses tuvieron niveles
desempleos históricos como nunca antes y
hay que señalar cuando hablan de
minorías el gran problema de la
izquierda es que las minorías solamente
existen si votan demócratas esta
convención está lleno de personas
catalogados de minorías que han hablado
lo que pasa es que bueno no los estamos
viendo y quién quiere saber esa lista
por favor que me escriben con mucho
gusto se las envío más allá de que es
récord público
donde está lleno de personas de la
minoría
y para los negros que están hablando que
apoyen al presidente pero repito lo que
pasa que para la izquierda estas
minorías no cuentan no son minorías
porque eso es parte de el 'esfuerzo'
draconiano de querer monopolizar en
determinados temas que realmente la
evidencia demuestra todo lo contrario y
si miramos los índices de la
recuperación económica e incluso bajo
esta pandemia es impresionante con
muchas de las pérdidas económicas
estamos a la par de donde estaba en la
presión de la economía el pensar que un
país puede llegar a una fundación a un
avance sin un respaldo económico repito
es ilusorio señor schilling retomando un
poco las palabras de la ex embajadora de
nicky reilly ella hizo un balance a
grosso modo de la gestión a nivel
internacional me confirman en este
momento va a empezar a intervenir otro
de los oradores vamos a conectarnos
entonces a la ciudad de charla
en carolina del norte y continuamos con
el análisis escuchamos
experimenta en 2020 ha puesto a prueba
nuestro país en formas que jamás
habíamos visto en décadas
cada cuatro años los estadounidenses se
unen para votar o para compartir
historias de cómo hacer mejor nuestro
país
mientras esta elección es entre donald
trump y joe biden
no es solamente de joe biden y dentón 8
mbps está cerca de la promesa de eeuu
es sobre usted y sobre mi los retos
nuestras esperanzas nuestros sueños
sobre cómo respondemos temas importantes
como la reforma política
porque querían generar más problemas que
una solución queremos una sociedad
que estoy porque estoy viviendo el sueño
de mi madre mis padres se divorciaron
cuando yo tenía 7 años y nos mudamos con
nuestros abuelos con mi hermano mi madre
y yo compartiendo un cuarto y una cama y
mi madre trabajó 16 horas para traernos
comida y un techo porque ella sabía que
si nosotros encontramos la oportunidad a
mejores y mayores cosas vendrían y yo
pensé que tendría el fútbol para ser
exitoso en la vida y más tras venir mi
primer año azul for soft ix este valle
falle español geografía inglés incluso
cívico pero créanlo después de siete
años en el senado sé que no soy el único
en el congreso
que falló la clase de cívica cuando mi
madre siempre me dijo tim y si paras a
la luna incluso si fallas estarás entre
las estrellas ella nunca perdió la fe en
mí incluso cuando yo había perdido la fe
en mí mismo su manera de criar la conocí
en verano a mi mentor chong él vio algo
en mí que yo no veía y empezó a
enseñarme enseñanzas de vida como tener
un trabajo pero crear trabajos iba a ser
mucho mejor que tener un ingreso que
podría cambiar mi estilo de vida pero
crear beneficios que podía cambiar a la
comunidad el planto las semillas que
serían zonas de oportunidad eso es algo
no encontrábamos el presidente hoy está
trayendo a 75 mil millones de dólares al
del sector privado dentro de las
comunidades
por ende oficiosos my life empecé a
recordar mi vida a ver que la educación
de calidad esto es lo más importante en
eeuu por eso lucho por escoger la
educación para que cada persona tenga
una buena educación de calidad golf o
sea virtual pública o privada donde un
padre tiene la opción su hijo va a tener
una mejor oportunidad y el presidente ha
luchado conmigo en eso luego la vida
empecé mi pequeño negocio y por eso sé
que en esto debo tener un código de
impuestos y que la economía debe mejorar
los demócratas no quieren que ustedes
sepan esto al trabajar el gobierno
empecé mi carrera en el congreso en el
empezó la guerra civil y ustedes deben
estar preguntando por qué un niño
se lanzó en este proceso político
los votantes me juzgaron o no por el
color de mi piel sino por el contenido
de mi carácter
vivimos en un mundo en el que ustedes
crean en lo malo que el racismo
económicamente y que polaricen estas
estas noticias polarizan
nosotros no estamos donde queremos estar
pero agradezco a dios todopoderoso
que no estamos donde estábamos antes
estamos luchando para ser mejores nos
tropezamos si nos tropezamos pero nos
volvemos a levantar y volveremos a
intentar
no vamos a renunciar en contra las
creencias radicales que ahora todo es
peor que en los 60 a sus 70 s tenemos
trabajo por hacer pero yo creo en la
bondad de eeuu la promesa que todas las
mujeres y los hombres son creados de
igual manera y si están viendo esta
noche
apuesto que ustedes también creen lo
mismo en los últimos cuatro años hemos
hecho un progreso tremendo hacia esa
promesa el presidente ha hecho la
economía más inclusive que nunca siete
millones de trabajos creados antes del
coi diecinueve y dos tercios de ellos
eran para las mujeres afroamericanos y
los hispanos
félix las oportunidades las zonas de
oportunidades que pusimos impuestos
extra encima los impuestos para
devolverles el dinero a las personas
reduciendo los impuestos a las madres
solteras su presidente
ayudó a estas personas estas madres
solteras y familias trabajadores y firmo
estas políticas y las hizo leyes y
nuestra nación es mejor por eso aunque
por eso les quiero preguntar a ustedes
estadounidenses público no solamente que
digan lo que el candidato dice sino que
vean atrás a lo que han de lo que han
hecho esta elección es acerca de su
futuro y es crítico
ver todo todo el panorama de panorama
del panorama de opinión
joe biden ha dicho que en los
afrodescendientes
que los niños pobres pueden ser igual de
inteligentes igual que el asado niños
blancos mientras sus palabras son unas
cosas sus acciones ni un lobo son de
otro nivel en 1994
y del dinero el proyecto de ley que puso
a una cantidad de afrodescendientes
detrás en las cárceles va a incluir en
sus de morfeo tram piso nuestro sistema
más justo
hayden le falló hoy es a nuestras
universidades afroamericanas
conseguir una vez más yo varios más para
limpiar el desorden by dentro afirmó
piscis es un gran fondo para las
escuelas y para darles fondos fox un
financiamiento permanente por la primera
vez en la historia y ahora yo vaivén
quiere ir por su dinero a no ser que
usted dos que usted sea un billonario
esa es una de las soluciones para la
pandemia
quieren tener obtener más dinero de su
bolsillo y dárselas
y de manhattan para que ellos le
reduzcan los impuestos
a los taxis por si la administración de
trump lo que hizo fue reducir los
impuestos para las familias trabajadoras
las madres solteras
así que mientras que debemos lo que yo
vaivén va a ser miren lo que ha hecho
miren sus acciones miren sus políticas
miren lo que ha hecho y lo que no ha
hecho mientras está hasta en washington
por 47 años señoras y señores
las personas no siempre ven esas fallas
porque ellos creen que tenemos un debate
político de dos visiones diferentes de
un debate esto no es lo que sucede a
nuestro lado trabajan las políticas
mientras yo os vaivén y los demócratas
quieren transformar lo que significa ser
estadounidense
y quiere una revolución cultural
un estado en estados unidos
fundamentalmente diferente quieren hacer
que nuestro país sea una utopía
socialista y la historia nos ha
demostrado que esto sólo nos lleva el
dolor y la miseria especialmente para
las personas trabajadoras que quieren
crecer y surgir
cuando en cambio debemos enfocarnos en
la promesa el viaje de eeuu yo sé y
conozco ese viaje por el 20mo
crecer
sufrió de la indignidad de ser sacado de
su escuela para ir a recoger algodón no
aprendió a leer ni escribir y aún así él
vivió bastante para ver a su nieto ser
el primer senador de eeuu hace nuestra
familia paso del algodón al congreso en
una vida y por eso creo que el siguiente
siglo eeuu debe ser mejor y va a ser
mejor que el anterior hay millones de
familias como la mía en toda esta nación
llenas de potencial buscando vivir el
sueño de eeuu y estoy aquí para decirles
a ustedes que apoyar al partido
republicano les da la mejor opción para
hacer este sueño realidad dios los
bendiga
y dios por favor continúa bendiciendo a
eeuu dios los bendiga a todos
[Música]
intervención de tim scott el senador por
el estado de carolina del sur hablando
de su experiencia personal como
ciudadano afrodescendiente que ha tenido
una carrera política surgiendo desde
algunos de los sectores más vulnerables
de su estado hasta llegar a liderar esta
región de la costa este de los eeuu
vamos a retomar entonces el debate aquí
en france24 con nuestros invitados y
nuestros corresponsables en algunos
minutos intervendrá el presidente de
donald trump para poner cierre a esta
primera noche de convención republicana
en la ciudad de charlotte en el estado
de carolina del norte en carlos le iba a
preguntar
antes de dar paso a esta intervención
del senador tim scott sobre el tema del
socialismo muchos han hablado sobre este
tema a lo largo de la jornada también
nuestros invitados lo han tocado
es un tema que se vuelve también común
en américa latina' lo tocan también
muchísimos los los políticos actuales
nos está volviendo un tema de lugares
comunes a esta hora de entregar un
mensaje y convencer al electorado y uno
de ellos es este tema del socialismo y
la supuesta amenaza que pueda haber en
eeuu por esta corriente política
carlos nuevamente tenemos algún
inconveniente con el sonido ya vamos a
retomar entonces la comunicación con él
para para poder hacer este análisis
mientras tanto entonces le doy paso al
señor julio schilling en la ciudad de
miami hablando de la política
internacional uno de los temas que tocó
la ex embajadora de la onu o de eeuu
ante la onu
nikki haley que fue una de las oradoras
de esta noche habló sobre los logros que
ha tenido el gobierno trump a lo largo
de sus cuatro años como presidente de
este país habló de este acercamiento que
ha tenido con israel y será el promotor
de un acuerdo de paz con palestina y
también un promotor del acercamiento que
hubo recientemente entre israel y el
gobierno de los emiratos árabes unidos-
y el acuerdo exitoso que ha alcanzado
con china o por lo menos ese
entendimiento que ha llevado a empezar a
ver un escalamiento de la atención señor
schilling sus impresiones sobre la
política exterior del presidente trump
que puede ser una carta también a jugar
de cara a su reelección
por supuesto y uno siempre tiene la
tentación de hablar de los logros
económicos y en esto el senador james
que es un trabajo formidable en cuanto
aplica a la minoría pero es fundamental
en relaciones exteriores de lo que hemos
visto el grupo islámico suní terrorista
isis aplastado totalmente
el romper el infame acuerdo que iba a
permitir al islamismo radical chiita la
dictadura de los ayatolás miran poder
producir bombas atómicas y fue
distanciado y ser aplicado sanciones
económicas para privar a esa dictadura
de fondo necesario para desestabilizar
el medio oriente hemos visto un acuerdo
de paz paradigmático que no hemos visto
desde hace veintipico de años con el
acuerdo de israel egipto en este caso
fue por la fe en la promoción directa de
esta administración de manera de que
hemos visto tu enfoque el privar de
recursos al comunismo castrista a su
colonia en venezuela en la lucha contra
el narcotráfico porque alguna la fuente
de la dictadura del socialismo del siglo
21 o sea es un enfoque completamente
distinto al de la administración previa
y sus frutos lo estamos viendo en cuanto
a la paz señor silín y también vemos la
otra cara de la moneda y es el
distanciamiento que hay por ejemplo con
la unión europea la canción
alemana angela merkel lo ha dicho varias
veces eeuu desde que llegó trompa al
poder no puede ser visto como ese aliado
estratégico que tenía alemania y la
unión europea haya habido muchas
discrepancias en torno a la otan a los
fondos que desembolsa en los países para
sostener esta alianza atlántica de eeuu
reclamándole más dinero alemania para
esta alianza atlántica y también un
distanciamiento con un aliado
estratégico y de larga data de eeuu que
es turquía un país de la otan con el que
ahora ha empezado o bueno no ha empezado
pero a lo largo de estos cuatro años ha
empezado a tener una serie de choques
por la cercanía con rusia por la
cercanía con irán por el tema de la
guerra en siria como analizar entonces
ese distanciamiento con europa
primero mira si miramos como nos basta
con ver la declaración del canciller
merkel hoy viviendo la rutina que por
favor castigue a las personas que
envenenaron al opositor ruso o sea
abriendo la pública por favor tome
cartas en el asunto cuando es
directamente el estado dictatorial ruso
el que tiene un papel en eso o sea hay
una falta del liderazgo extraordinario
en europa entonces el hecho de que
europa que efectivamente hemos heredado
muchas cosas buenas también hemos
hablado muchas cosas malas el nazismo el
comunismo de manera de que no son el
ejemplo de de seguir cuando vemos que el
reino unido francia y alemania han
enseñado en contra de seguir las
sanciones contra la dictadura y dirán
pues realmente no son un modelo y en
cuanto turquía
el factor favorable de turquía en el
medio oriente y ha dejado de ser por la
inclinación hacia el islamismo radical
del régimen que está en el poder ahora
en turquía y ya turquía no es la turquía
que fue en otro momento y francamente la
otan debería de cuestionar si sigue
siendo viable que esté en su seno sí y
sin duda alguna turquía es un jugador
importante en ese puente que puede tener
con los países de medio oriente dadas
las circunstancias que se presentan con
esa relación entre eeuu y los países del
golfo que son países importantes para la
economía precisamente porque son
potencias petroleras son las 10 de la
noche en punto hora de bogotá vamos a
hacer un repaso por las principales
noticias destacadas hasta esta hora aquí
en france 24
y termino el primer día de la convención
republicana en el que el presidente de
donald trump y su vicepresidente mike
pence fueron ya confirmados como los
candidatos para las elecciones
presidenciales de noviembre de este año
más de 30 millones de estudiantes
mexicanos iniciaron este lunes el año
escolar desde casa y por televisión una
medida histórica para contener el avance
del hobby 19 que deja más de 560.000
casos y 60.000 muertos en ese país
el hospital charité de la ciudad de
berlín confirmó que el opositor ruso
alexéi navalni fue envenenado con una
sustancia química que aún no ha sido
identificada el político se mantiene en
estado crítico pero estable la unión
europea' solicitó una investigación
independiente a rusia sobre este caso
y retomamos entonces el análisis que
estamos haciendo de este primer día de
la convención del partido republicano en
la ciudad de charlotte en el estado de
carolina del norte en carlos áreas en la
ciudad de bogotá que es nuestro analista
y también él es experto en comunicación
política y nos ayuda a entender un poco
esta dinámica de las convenciones y un
poco el juego que tiene el presidente
trampa para vender su propuesta como
candidato a la reelección para estar
cuatro años más allí en la casa blanca y
le estábamos preguntando antes de perder
la conexión con él carlos sobre estos
puntos comunes que se empiezan a
presentar si es estratégico empezar a
hablar de estos mismos puntos de
socialismo de una supuesta amenaza del
socialismo para eeuu
dos cualidades antes de responderle lo
que vamos a encontrar de aquí en
adelante y creo que sí pudiendo hacer un
ejercicio de bajar todo este un software
de análisis para hacer un análisis de
discurso muy bien detallado y específico
con un atractivo cualquier software de
análisis podríamos encontrar calcados
los discursos de toda la familia el
trump y eso es muy conveniente para el
diseño estratégico ahora bien qué tal
pues qué tan innovador puede hacer es
otra cosa pero en términos de lo que
significa el ejercicio persuasivo o
manipulador o como lo quieran llamar
porque no estoy casado con ninguno de
los dos es muy importante ahora viene el
tema de recoger otra vez la palabra el
comunismo y el socialismo y lo que en
colombia se conoce como el
castrochavismo por ejemplo es si es
simplemente recoger desde la etiqueta
para poder generar una ruta mucho más
expedita entre el discurso político del
político obviamente y el ciudadano es
decir está construyendo un mantra está
construyendo un sistema de creencias
alrededor de algo que entre comillas es
muy difícil es muy difuso de explicar
para el ciudadano de a pie pero que
dentro del imaginario dentro del este
central qué tipo soy se construye con la
palabra socialismo comunismo
castrochavismo es muy fácil de vender
básicamente lo que quiero decirles es
que lo que están haciendo es generar un
mantra de recordación en una impronta de
creencia para aquella persona que no
necesita saber de fondo que es lo que
verdaderamente significa un sistema
ideológico
al norteamericano me quedan pocos
minutos para finalizar este análisis y
quiero hacer las conclusiones quiero
comenzar con nuestros corresponsales en
nueva york y en la ciudad de washington
en nueva york' mamen sanz a balance de
lo que vimos esta noche de lo que
podemos comenzar a ver a partir del
martes para las próximas fechas de esta
convención sus impresiones
y pues yo creo que esperábamos que esta
noche fuera una noche llena de sorpresas
como trump también como el presidente
don al tan también esperaba y creo que
ha sido bastante más descafeinada por
así decirlo de lo que vimos la primera
noche de las convenciones demócratas
hemos visto una batería de discursos en
la que han faltado pesos pesados dentro
del partido del pasado como vimos en la
convención demócrata expresidentes
apoyando la labor de donald trabas y
como vimos entre los demócratas pues el
presidente barack obama y demás luego
también ha sido muy interesante el hecho
de que no se ha pronunciado en ningún
momento la cifra de muertos sobre el
coronavirus y ha llamado la atención que
todo momento se han referido a él como
el virus chino algo que precisamente se
está pidiendo desde las autoridades
internacionales que se evite por la
controversia que puede dar lugar y diana
en la ciudad de washington sus
impresiones y conclusiones de esta
primera jornada
bueno vemos una convención en la que el
presidente y vicepresidente fueron
nominados para que no quedara dudas de
la unidad que tiene el partido
republicano frente a estas elecciones
donde los temas centrales fueron el
derecho y protección del uso y tenencia
de armas también la protección de los
departamentos de policía y generación de
trabajos y en donde en varias
oportunidades en estos discursos se
mostró a los demócratas como peligrosos
socialistas el tema de hoy fue la tierra
de oportunidades y promesas mañana será
un tema similar en donde el tema central
será la generación de empleo y en donde
también participarán los dos hijos de
donald trump la primera dama hablará
desde la casa blanca y se esperan
también en nuevas apariciones del
presidente don al sol gracias de anna
por replantearnos aquí un poco de lo que
vamos a ver mañana un poco de la agenda
prevista para este segundo día de la
convención republicana julio schilling
en la ciudad de miami sus impresiones de
este primer día importante para su
partido el republicano
con santiago primero te doy las gracias
a ti y a todo el equipo a tu lado a tu
alrededor y detrás de las cámaras de
france 24 realmente le hacen un gran
favor a una sociedad libre a través de
todo el continente de traer este
programa en español que es tan
importante si cree le agradezco y los
felicito
pero es muy importante tomando en cuenta
la importancia de esta elección porque
quien no entiende realmente lo que está
en juego y en tu última pregunta
santiago acerca de el socialismo y la
respuesta de él tal vez la falta de
concienciación en una sociedad como la
estadounidense de entender
conceptualmente lo que es eso sí se
entiendo lo que es la teoría y crítica
que proviene del colegio frankfurt un
bastión del marxismo directamente es
parte de del formato ideológico del
marxismo es lo que estamos viendo en la
plataforma política de blackwater y
parte de lo que ha recogido el partido
demócrata quieran o no entiéndanlo o no
eso es una realidad por eso es
fundamental que si se hable y se trate
estos temas para que se entiendan todo
lo que está en juego el socialismo tiene
numerosos rostros y estamos viendo uno
de ellos por la plataforma del partido
demócrata
carlos dos minutos para su conclusión
adelante
pues mire básicamente lo que yo
encuentro es que va a ser muy difícil
para los demócratas ganarse esta
elección a pesar de que las encuestas
hoy están lanzando hay o guarden por
encima es muy complicado porque
básicamente trump sabe muy bien lo que
hace y sabe muy bien cómo hacerlo ahora
bien eso no significa que ya haya ganado
significa que por primera vez
tendríamos la posibilidad de a pesar de
lo que dicen las grandes medios de tener
una reelección de trump a pesar de todo
lo que ha conseguido a pesar de muchas
críticas que le han lanzado creo que los
norteamericanos en estar en polvo de
polarización y que lo están haciendo muy
bien en la construcción del discurso en
esta convención carlos muchas gracias
por esta conclusión a julio schilling en
la ciudad de miami también a carlos
arias en la ciudad de bogotá
luís montes en la ciudad de nueva york
que estaba con nosotros hace unos
momentos y nuestras dos corresponsales
mamen sala en nueva york' y diana
castañeda en la ciudad de washington
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
haber compartido con nosotros estas
impresiones haber analizado y explicado
para la audiencia de américa latina'
este punto importante
de eeuu a ustedes gracias también por la
sintonía en nombre de todo el equipo la
reacción de france 24 el equipo del
master y la traducción del aura garzón
les entregamos esta primera jornada de
la convención del partido republicano a
la cita es mañana a la misma hora con la
segunda jornada y también desde la
ciudad de charlotte en el estado de
carolina del norte muchas gracias por su
sintonía siga con nosotros
[Música]